our first speaker of the afternoon in
Catania Swami who will tell us about
good LP for retiring and by jumping from
thank Sanjeev and thanks to the
organizers for inviting me here so so
yeah I'm going to be talking about some
vehicle routing problems which is
something that I've been interested in
for some time and and in particular
designing approximation algorithms for
these proms so one of the things that
that kind of it's you when you're
thinking about approximation algorithms
for vehicle routing problems is these
are we don't have too good and
understanding of how to effectively use
LPS and LP based machinery for these
proms so in this talk I'm going to talk
about two such problems orienteering and
related prong called regret bounded
vehicle routing for which we we now have
a have a reasonable LP ways of
effectively leveraging LPS right and
this is joint work with Zac fixed at the
University of Alberta okay so let me
start by defining the orienteering
problem so so the problem is as follows
we are given some metric space and a
starting node or root R and and we're
given some rewards on the nodes so PI of
V is going to denote the reward of V and
and I have some and and we'll always
assume that the reward of the root node
is 0 they're given some lengths bound
and what I want is is to find a path
starting at are that visits as many or
collects as much reward subject to the
constraint that the length of the path
is at most B it's by of P is always
going to denote the reward and there are
two versions of this one in which I'm
just told the starting node R and the
and the version so this is a potential
solution and if I'd admire its metric
ride it collects the reward of 24 and
there's the version that's called the
point-to-point problem where I've I'm
given both the start node and the end
node and and again it's the same thing I
have a budget of B and I want to collect
the maximum reward
and both these problems are and be hard
so just just to make sure we're on the
same page so and this is a maximization
problem alpha approximation means that I
get where alpha is larger than 1 means
that I get two more at least the optimum
by alpha okay so this turns out to be a
fairly fundamental vehicle routing
problem I mean it's it's fairly well
motivated I mean it's been mood it can
be motivated from the perspective of I
mean planning paths for vehicles subject
to I mean you you have limited petrol or
I mean there's a robot with limited
battery it's also been used to plan
travel itineraries and and something
that's a little less immediate is that
it's this procedure orienteering comes
up as a procedure in designing
approximation algorithms for other
vehicle routing problems like minimum
latency proms and also if you want to
solve these vehicle routing problems
computationally so one one kind of
general framework is that you kind of
write a huge LP a set covering style LP
or what what we call a configuration LP
which has variables or parts and if you
want to solve this computationally using
kind of branch cut and price method or
cutting plane method then the subroutine
that you need to solve is called the
pricing problem turns out to be a
orienteering problem right so to
elaborate a bit on on this portion here
let me also define the second problem in
the title which is this regret bounded
vehicle routing problem so again the
input is the same we have a we have a
root R and and I mean we're in this sort
of typical vehicle running world where
we these nodes or or clients we want to
visit them and and we want to have some
measure of I mean the goodness of her
out which is which could be for example
minimizing client delays so so if I if I
were to think of for example the the
path version of TSP that David was
talking about that that could be
equivalently phrased as find one path
that visits all the nodes and and the
there's two so usually it stated as the
length of the pot but I can think of
that equivalently as minimizing the
maximum client delay right so maybe this
this is a solution involving two routes
right but one issue with this objective
is that is that it doesn't take into
account that I mean they're clients that
could be closer to the to the root or
the starting node and some clients that
are further away and you would kind of
expect that main clients that are closer
should face a lower delay than clients
that are further so I mean in this
solution the sort of the red and happy
faces are unhappy because they're kind
of closer to the root then this other
guy which is farther away but but there
if I think of the delay as the as the
length of the paths that's used to visit
them then they're although they're
closer to the root they are suffering a
larger delay than someone that's further
away so this is like saying that
although I'm in Waterloo and there's a
package that's being shipped from
Toronto it takes me more than the time
that it takes for that package to go to
China right which is which is I mean I'd
be pretty too satisfied with that so
this is a kind of a source of
dissatisfaction and so what what can be
what some measure that can that sort of
takes that into account so so one
measure which is called the regret in
the in the vehicle routing literature is
so I want to compare the the waiting
time of a client versus the the least
possible waiting time which is the
shortest path distance from the depot to
the node so by waiting time I'm always
going to denote that by if I'm if I'm
using a path P to visit the node that's
CP or V is always going to denote the
time the length of the portion of a path
up to that node V and I'm going to use
DV to denote the the shortest path
distance from the root to that node so
I'm interested in so that regret is the
difference between these two quantities
and and so what I could ask or one
version of the problem is that I'm given
some Rickett regret bound R and I want
to find routes that met the minimum
number of paths that I need so that I
can visit every one
and ensure that everyone faces a regret
of it most at most all right so this is
the regret bounded very crowning problem
any any questions about the definition
of this problem or or orienteering yes I
want to minimize the number of parts
that I'm using right so yes I could do
that and that would ensure zero regret
but we would like to do better okay good
so so here's here's one way of attacking
this problem so so my parts in this in
this talk are always going to be rooted
so I may not always say rooted but
they're always going to start at the
root so define that regret of a path to
be just the regret of the end node right
so again that's just the length minus
the distance of the end node from the
root so in in orienteering in previous
works and orienteering this was called
the excess I'm going to use the term
regret because that's that's what the
sort of literature on vehicle routing
uses so so here's a formulation of the
problem a simple I can write down a
simple set covering formulation so if I
if I look at the collection of all parts
that have regretted most are so those
are the those are the parts that I can
use to cover my notes now I want to find
I have a variable for each such part I
want to minimize the number of parts
that I use and I want to ensure that
every part every note is covered so an
integer solution here is exactly what we
want so there's a simple standard set
car LP right so my sets are these parts
and I would I want to cover all these
notes right so so now the set color
thing is useful because it immediately
tells us that well we could potentially
get a log in approximation what do I
need to get a log and approximation I
need to be able to run the greedy
algorithm which means that I need to be
able to find at every step the set that
covers the maximum number of new notes
all right the
the N Load of the box and not okay so
okay so I guess yeah good question so it
turns out that regret only increases as
you move along the path so if I bound
the regret of the end node then all
nodes have regretted more start yeah so
good question Thanks so so right so for
the greedy algorithm I need to find
apart the greedy step is to find a path
that covers the maximum number of new
nodes and this is exactly orienteering
right so orienteering if I had something
for orienteering I could immediately use
standard set cover machinery and get a
login approximation in fact I can do
much better here so this this LP was in
some previous work we showed that it has
a constant integrality gap so it's a
it's a structured setting so we can
exploit that structure but now so how
does this give a constant approximation
algorithm well we need to be able to
solve this LP either exactly or
approximately and you can do that in
various ways I mean you could use the
ellipsoid method in which case you would
look at the dual and it turns out the
dual separation problem is also an
orienteering prong or you could use
multiplicative weights machinery and
there again the problem that you need to
solve it boils down to an error in
tearing problem yes just confuse me so I
don't see why the grid just increases
over third life I mean if you could
imagine a path that sort of loops back
to the root then I'm not okay so I guess
I'm not counting I'm not thinking of
parts ending at the root so at a point
that happens to be closer to the root
then the next to the last point and yeah
but yeah good great question
so so I could I could think of solving
this approximately in a sort of so that
I get a theoretical guarantee but and
also again if you wanted to solve this
computationally a column generation
procedure would involve solving this
pricing crawl which is orienteering
right so hopefully I mean that gives
some sort of
evidence for ya this orienteering turns
out to be a problem that comes up in
various settings and and so what do we
know about this problem or what can we
get for this wrong question
I'm staying in the undirected metric
yeah right so yes but regret actually
can be viewed as an asymmetric metric
but it's a special kind of facing
literature okay let me not confuse
things right we are seeing and it's an
it's an undirected metric space and all
our problems are in this undirected
metric so here's what we get so we we
get an LP relaxation for orienteering
rooted orienteering and an LP rounding
algorithm that gives a three
approximation right so this is a this is
the first LP based guarantee so and
that's how it fits into the theme of the
stock into the theme of this workshop
now this is not the first constant
approximation so there are previous
approaches and very nice ideas in this
approaches that all these previous
approaches use dynamic programming in a
in a nice clever way so they the
previous approaches use dynamic
programming to find together some sub
parts which are stitched together using
another dynamic program and the supports
in turn are found using another DPR or
using a key MST algorithm right and this
was I mean this was pioneered by Blum it
all who gave the first constant factor
approximation and then improved by by
nickel and others and and by Chandra and
and others so here so this DP approaches
is nice but it's a what we are going to
get is a is a simpler cleaner algorithm
and I think more than just this this
specific problem I think what's what I
feel is promising is that this the ideas
may lead to strong LPS for other vehicle
routing props which is which is I think
which would be great in order to sort of
get a better understanding of how to
design algorithms so the strong so so in
particular using what we do here it
gives them
rumens for for the regret bounded
vehicle routing problem and I mean as
often happens LP based insights we
expect our versatile and will carry over
to other variants so there's some
evidence of that but we'd like much more
and I should say here that we don't end
up improving the approximation so
Chandra and others give a 2 plus epsilon
approximation which is still the best
known factor for this but I do think
that I mean I do think that our analysis
of the LP integrality app is not tight I
mean I feel that we should be able to
get a 2 but we don't know how to get
there so this was so rooted orienteering
for the point-to-point version where I'm
given both endnotes one can actually
reduce this to a version of rooted
orienteering losing a factor of two so
so this is we call this the regret
version of rooted orienteering the
difference is that instead of a length
bound on the paths we are instead of
bound in the path length we have bound
on the record of the path so this this
is I find this somewhat intrigued in
that usually when you when you go from
an unrooted problem to a rooted one
there's a you you tend to violate
something in the constraint like the
length of the Frog the the path that
you're finding but here we don't lose
any in such factor and I think
understanding better what's going on
here may may have some further
implications so so this these two
results combined also give you an LP for
for point-to-point of orienteering with
a factor of six integrality yeah and
finally for the regret bounded problem
we again get get LPS with small
integrality gap so compact is always
going to refer to polynomial size
polynomial number of variables and
constraints and these two LPS are
actually quite different so one is one
is just using insights that we get for
or in here
you can get a you can sort of so as I
mentioned if you look at the LP for the
set cover LP and if you look at the dual
there's an orienteering problem hidden
there and and one can kind of use this
LP relax the LP relaxation that we have
apply that for the dual and then and
then work things out and that gives an
LP for for the regret bounded vehicle
routing problem and we also have an a
better LP which exploits the structure
of the problem both actually give
improvements over the previous constant
factor and and the sort of the current
best thing that we have uses this
unorthodox LP gives a fifteen
approximation and I should also mention
here that I mean the set covering LP is
it's a huge LP so solving that takes a
lot of work and here we have compact LP
so although this was not our primary
motivation they do give substantial
improvements in running time so in this
talk I'm going to I'm going to focus on
the on the orienteering result and and
hopefully I should be able to describe
pretty much all of it in the remaining
it's ten minutes okay so here's my LP
for orienteering so I'm going to buy
direct my graph so just replace every
edge of it to pirate by directed edges
I'm always going to view my path as
being directed away from the route and
and let's say we we know the node on the
optimum path that set maximum distance
from the root so let's call that W right
so that may not be the end node so as as
is indicated by this picture but it is
the it is the maximum distance node on
the optimal path so I'm going to use two
sets of variables one to indicate
whether a node lies on this lies on the
spot that's that u W and and these X is
there's always a superscript W to
indicate this case here to indicate
whether I'm using an arc on my path
right so my objective is to maximize my
reward which is just this expression and
then I have some constraints that kind
of encode that I have a part so
because I'm looking for a parts I know
that in degree is always going to be
well it's either going to be equal to
the in degree or for the end node it's
going to be it's going to be one and the
out degree is going to be zero we have a
metric space so I'm not thinking of
repeating back I'm just I'm just
thinking of using shortcuts and using
every edge at most once and I want to
make sure that my guess things are
compatible with my guess so I'm not
going to visit nodes which are at
further distance from my guests no W I
wonder that's my that's including my
length constraint and then I have to I
have to encode the usual kind of thing
that's done in TSP that I everything is
connected
or rather connected from the root so if
I look at a set s which separates a node
u from the root then what this
constraint is saying is that if your LP
is saying that you're visiting that node
then it better be that you have some
arcs that are being used to visit that
right that's what this constraint is
and and this is just encoding that I am
I'm actually going to visit W right okay
so so so this I'm going to call sort of
a vector X which has these in degree at
least out degree constraint I'm going to
call that a pre flow and this can be
viewed as a relaxation of a routed path
and I said that we are looking for a
compact LP now these are exponentially
many constraints but there's a standard
kind of trick that we can use that I
mean this is kind of saying that the min
cut I under this under in this graph
with capacities given by X A's is at
least something you can replace that by
flow constraints so you can get an
extended formulation which is compact
okay so that's the LP again now some
basic sort of sanity check here my
constraints it's it's not hard to see
that the the constraints ensure that no
node is visited more than extent of to
an extent larger than one right that
would be bad and also the constraints
also ensure that indeed although I have
not explicitly said this I don't visit
notes that are not compatible with my
guess so that's just a basic thing we
would expect as a sanity check
and although I'm not going to get into
this in detail
I'm just let me just mention that we
don't actually need to guess this node W
there are ways of avoiding it all right
we get a larger LP but but that can be
done okay so so what's the idea behind
rounding the LP solution so here's the
the key inside and this is a great tool
to actually sort of take home regarding
when you can express it that a pre flow
can always be expressed as a packing of
arbor essences so so my ex was a pre
flow and the and the key inside is that
so for example I could have that as my
pre flow then I can always Express this
as that dominates a convex combination
of what I am
call just out arbor essences routed at
our so each of these structures is is a
directed tree that's routed out from our
it's not spanning it's it's it's it it
spans some notes but not necessary all
the nodes and so what this picture is
saying is that you can you can always
take X express it as a as a obtain a
collection of arbor essences with some
weights such that that X is is at least
these this weighted combination of these
characteristic vectors right so so let
me say that more precisely so this is
this follows from some nice arborescens
backing results of bung ensign at all
and the the formally what what we are
saying is that we can we can take this X
and get a bunch of trees rooted out from
our and corresponding weights the
weights add up to 1 the if I look at any
arc and the total weight of the trees
containing this arc that's at most the
LP value of that arc and on the other
hand if I look at the total weight of
trees containing a node u that's at
least the extent to which the LP visits
that no
right and from this it also follows that
every of each of these trees contains my
guests note W and none of them contains
any note that that has larger distance
in W right okay so what's my goal now so
and and these things can be obtained in
polynomial time right so so now my goal
is to show that given this the structure
I can I can utilize this to gain at
least opt by three opt is the LP optimum
right so so here's the algorithm so I'm
gonna get these pairs and now what I'm
going to do is I'm actually looking for
parts right so but I'm just going to do
this doubling and shortcutting convert
every tree to a root W path and I lose a
factor of two but but not quite two so I
don't have to double the edges on the
tree that lie on the route to W path of
the tree so I get the savings of DW
which is going to be important so so if
I look at the regret of this pot so the
regret again was the length minus the
distance of the end node I get a regret
off so if I look at the sorry if I look
at the gamma waited lens that adds up to
at most twice my budget minus the minus
the distance of W and so the regret it
adds up to it at most twice B minus TW
okay so and and also what I know is that
if I look at the gamma weighted reward
that I collect that's that's at least
optimal
so now let's let's for simplicity and
being really if I if I were if I was
really lucky and I didn't have this
factor of two and if it turned out that
all my parts not just the gamma weighted
regret but actually each path had regret
at most this quantity be minus DW that
I'd be good because if the regret is be
minus W and it's an RW path it has
length at most W and then I'm getting
the average the reward is at least op so
there's got to be some path which is
actually going to be opt so if I were
really lucky and each of these parts had
regret at most this much then actually
I'd be getting the optimum so I'm not
going to be that lucky but but so what I
need now is a way of converting
something which gets regret twice kind
of my target into the bound that we
would like so if if I had a bound of B
minus DW then that'd be great for us so
here's what we're going to do and this
is this is also kind of a standard tool
that's used in previous work that if I
have if I'm shooting for regret R and I
get beta times that regret I can always
break it up into rooted parts 1 plus
beta rooted paths each each having the
right value of regret so I'm just going
to apply that the target that I'm
shooting for and I mean let this is just
a picture that that shows that so I'm
just going to apply this using this as
my target so when I do this I'm going to
get a total weight of of three in my
parts and each of each path is going to
end at some node U but because of my
guess W I know that this the distance of
U from the root is at most the distance
of W so the two things together mean
that I get a feasible collection of
parts the gamma weight of these parts is
is at most 3 and I get a reward of at
least opt so that's my factory
that's the algorithm in the proof and so
to wrap things up so what I showed you
is a three approximation using this this
LP this is the first LP based guarantee
we get results for others for the
point-to-point version and retreat
bounded vehicle routing something that I
that we can do is that we don't actually
need to solve the I mean there's a
combinatorial algorithm that that gives
the same guarantee with the the arborist
answers that we need can be obtained
combinatorially and in fact you only
need two arborist senses so this so did
we get a code so one can get a
combinatorial three approximation and
what's open is this nailing down the
exact integrality gap so it'll be great
to actually show so III believe that two
is the right answer and it'd be great to
actually show that we do have a I mean
it's easy to get a lower bound of for
third on the integrality gap without
actually working hard at all so I guess
one could look for a stronger lower
bound and two sort of generalizations of
orienteering that I would love to solve
our so once called deadlines TSP where
every node has a different deadline by
which you need to visit in order to
collect its reward and then there's a
submodular generalization of it where I
mean the the reward is a submodular
function of the node set of the path and
I mean so it'd be great if the ideas in
here can be useful but it's also clear
that I mean you need some some
substantial new ideas and that's all I
have to say
[Applause]
yes so a question I asked you many times
Eddie but does this give you any
progress on if you wanted to minimize
total regret let's say you just have one
you know one vehicle and now you want to
optimize total if you if you have just
one vehicle then then yes so we actually
have a to approximation for that that
you can also obtain from some other work
that so this this paper by Chaudhary at
all that has a three point five nine for
minimum latency shows that you can get a
tree whose cost is at most the the
minimum cost path that visits so they
don't quite get this but for for the
problem that you're asking you can get a
spanning tree of length at most of the
the smallest Hamiltonian path and so
when you that actually gives you a to
approximation for the regret some of the
regrets sorry okay no I don't know about
that yeah I mean we have some in order
to get a log by log log but I don't know
to get a constant yeah
any other questions inside the directory
so I mean this this bong ensign thing
will still work but I guess the yeah so
I mean the question is yeah how do you
convert a tree to a pot so maybe if you
had some if you had added some extra
constraints talking about sort of the
order of so the short answer is yeah I
don't know but I think this maybe you
could you could write a more
sophisticated LP that has kind of
ordering variables between the nodes so
that you can kind of encode in your LP
that you have to be a certain cost
yeah but I don't all find I don't know
yeah I guess that would be like a
special case of some modular no yeah I
don't know yeah
[Applause]